من جهتها اعلن القيادي بجبهه الخلاصه
الوطنيه جوهر بن مبارك بدا اضراب عن
الطعام بسبب ما اعتبره تعمد اداره السجن
التنكيل به وتغيير مكان اقامته في ظروف
وصفها بالسيئه بتعليمات من سلطه الانقلاب
كما قال في منشور على صفحته الرسميه في
فيسبوك وراى المحامي وعضو هيئه الدفاع عن
بن مبارك كريم مرزوقي ان اضراب بعض
الموقوفين عن الطعام هو نتيجه تراكميه لما
يحصل للمعتقلين منذ اسبوعين بالسجن وكان
نجوم نشط السياسي والامين العام السابق
لحزب التيار الديمقراطي غازي الشواشي قد
اكد في وقت سابق دخول والده في اضراب عن
الطعام رفضا لما وصفه بسياسه التنكيل به
في السجن
اعتبرت الجامعه العامه للبلديات وهي هيئه
لتجمع رؤساء البلديات اعتبرت قرار حل
للمجالس البلديه قبل مده قصيره من انتهاء
مدتها القانونيه خرقا للقانون وشددت
الجامعه على اجراء الانتخابات البلديه في
موعدها خصوصا مع انتهاء المده النيابيه
للمجالس الحاليه وكان الرئيس التونسي قد
اعلن حل المجالس البلديه وتعويضها بهيئات
تاثير مؤقت وتشكو المجلس البلديه من نقص
في التمويلات وسط شكوى متكرره من
التونسيين من تدني الخدمات وتراكم
النفايات ما تسبب في مشاكل بيئيه في مناطق
عده
معنى من تونس مراسل الجزيره حافظ ريبح اذا
حافظ ملف جديد اضيف الى ملفات الملفات
الخلافيه والمعقده في تونس موضوع حل مجالس
البلديات اضافه الى مساله الاعتقالات
المستمره والمواقف منها لا سيما موقف حركه
النهضه الاخير
نعم حسن دعني ابدا من حيث انتهيت وهو
الاعتقالات وتواصل سجن عدد من قيادات جبهه
الخلاص وايضا من المحامين من اطياف سياسيه
مختلفه في الحقيقه لا ينتمون فقط لجبهه
الخلاص هنالك عده قضايا بعضها يتعلق بما
تصفه السلطات هنا بتامر على امن الدوله
والبعض الاخر بقضايا اخرى منفرده يصفها
المحامون واهالي المساجين الذين يوصفون
بالسياسيين اليوم في تونس بانها قضايا
مفتعله على خلفيه نشاطهم السياسي ثم اضرب
جوع قد اطلقه عدد من هؤلاء المساجين على
راسهم جوهر بن مبارك وغازي الشواشي
المحامي والامين العام الاسبق للتياري
الديمقراطي على خلفيه ما اعتبره تنكيلا
بهم في السجن وطالبوا بضمانات وغيرها
ضمانات لحقوقهم وبتعامل يحترم حقوق
الانسان في السجن هذا من ناحيه الاعتقالات
التي قلت تتواصل وطالت عددا لا باس به من
الشخصيات السياسيه على خلفيه ملفات مختلفه
لعلى ابرزها ملف سيف مخلوف عبد الحميد
الجلاسي خيام التركي
وغيرهم عصام الشابي وغيرهم من المساجين
يوم امس تم ايقاف ايضا ناشطين ينتمون
لحركه النهضه في جهه باجه تقول الحركه ان
الامر جاء على خلفيه نشاط لهم مع جبهه
الخلاص المعارضه التي يبدو من خلال
التعامل مع اعضائها ان السلطه صارت
تعتبرها كانها تنظيم محظور او ممنوع وجبه
الخلاص ليس لها كيان قانوني ليست حسبا
فعليا اليوم السلطه تقول ان بعض قيادات
هذه الجبهه
متهمون او تعلقت بهم شبهات بما تصفه تامرا
على امن الدوله وبالتالي هي تضيق على ما
يبدو على عمل هذه الجبهه على كل ليس رد
رسمي حول هذه
الايقافات ولكن عمليات السجن ما زالت
متواصله تجدر الاشاره الى ان البشير
العكرمي
القاضي
ووكيل الجمهوريه السابق هنا في تونس قد
اودع في السجن ايضا بعد انتهاء اجل
التحقيق معه والايقاف التحفظي الى اضافه
الى ذلك ما زالت قضيه البلديات وحل كل
المجالس البداديه من قبل رئيس قيس سعيد
بمرسوم متفاعله هنالك من رحب بهذه القضيه
ولكن احزاب سياسيه وعدد من الشخصيات
السياسيه نددت بهذا الاجراء وشجبته
اعتبرته ان القيس سعيد يريد ان تمتد سلطته
حتى الى السلطه المحليه وقالوا ان هذا هذا
القرار ياتي في اطار في اطار التعويم
واخفاء الفشل الذي يصفه ما يصفونه بفشل
قيس سعيد في اداره البلاد ومحاوله اخفاء
الازمات المتعدده الاقتصاديه الاجتماعيه
وايضا السياسيه الخانقه كما يقولون التي
تعيشها البلاد لا سيما وانهم يعتبرون ان
هذا القرار انه جاء بمثابه في الوقت
الضائع كما يعتبر معرض هو سعيد لان هذه
المجالس البلديه في الفعل انهى تقريبا
مدتها لانه تم انتخابها عام 2018 وكان من
المفترض ان تكون هنالك انتخابات جديده
خلال شهر مايو من هذا العام لتجديدها نعم
حسن شكرا لك حافظ مريده حدثتنا من تونس